so it's 1 plus X 4 to the power 6 1
steps all to the power 6 ok this is kind
of nice for us because if I let y equal
1 in this case right and you can see it
is immaterial whether I like this
as X plus 1 to the power of 4 or 1 plus
X to the power 4 I'll let you try and
work out in a second why're you they
might write it the second way rather
than the first way okay
just have a look at this line here so
everywhere I see why I'm just gonna
write 1 right and 1 to any power still 1
so I'm gonna get this no more Y well Y
squared
no more Y cubed and then that's just the
one ok so I can see my 1 46:41 happening
very clearly right what's going to
happen when I go to the power 6 one of
the things getting to do just like I did
is you're gonna need to draw yourself a
passwords triangle okay I probably go up
to at least the tenth nerve okay
you don't necessarily gonna have to
write out the full expansion but
sometimes you just want to know
something interesting like in the middle
right and you don't want to have to go
through this whole long expansion
process because it's time-consuming okay
I'm just interested in the actual
numbers now I've written up to 6 so I'm
looking at this row here you see that
okay
so let's give this a go what's the
difference by the way if I swap this
down here all I'm doing like in terms of
the sum it's the same thing but as I
write it
I'm writing it in reverse order okay so
I'm writing it I want my powers to
increase because I don't know about you
but I count one two three four five
rather than 5 4 3 2 1
so we're a start with a 1 which is
really 1 to the power 6 ok there is
my next one is six next 150 X square 20x
cubed 15 I'm now climbing back down next
to the 4 6 X to the 5 and if I've chosen
the runner correctly I end with a
coefficient of 1 and my power should
match what I started with tada
there it is okay so really quickly if I
were to put in a minus sign there what
difference would it make
well I hope for way to write this just
like when we're doing how to manage
before it's kind of like this right so
I'm still doing that it's just the
everywhere I see an X really I'm gonna
swap it with a negative x okay so for
instance have a look at this guy's see
how there's just one this is a single X
10 right so that will become negative
right but because there are two x's here
take a negatives cancel I can just leave
that that's fine in fact each
alternating term odd number so be
negative no it's fine right sorry yeah
yes right and this one here okay so you
start to get the hang of it all right
now we're gonna unravel more of the
patterns as we go just to spin you out a
little more before I sit you to the
exercise okay bear with me what's the
sum of the terms in this royal Paskus
Rayleigh
so I'll just wave now here's that again
I'm gonna pose to you the most important
question what's the most important
question why why why does it do that why
is it to him why is this why is this
doing this and why is this doing that
and I could keep going but I'm just
gonna leave it for a few extra lessons